بعد سبع سنوات من رفع القضيه وسبع ساعات
متواصله من المداولات يوم الجمعه قضت
محكمه الجنايات الفرنسيه بالسجن ست سنوات
بحق المغني المغربي سعد المجرد وادانته
بتهمه الاغتصاب اللي كانت رفعتها المدعيه
عليه لورا في 2016 وشافت المحكمه في
الادله ووصف المدعي عليه ما هو ثابت ودقيق
وشافت في كلام سعد لمجرد العكس وقالت انه
روايته واقوال متغيره ومتبدله وعليه صدر
الحكم بالسجن ومنعه من دخول فرنسا بعدها
خمس سنوات والحكم قابل للاستئناف خلال
عشره ايام للي مو متابعه التفاصيل ساعد
اولورو روايتهم متفقه في الجزء الاول بس
المتعلق بانه ملتقوا في نايت كلوب رجعت
معاه على الاوتيل رقصوه تبادل القبل لكن
بعدها عاد بتختلف رواياتهم هي بتقول انه
تهجم عليها جبرها تخلع ملابسها ضربها لمن
رفضته وبعدين اغتصبها وبتقول انه كان تحت
تاثير الك والمخدرات وهو بينفو تماما وهو
بينفي تماما انه صارت علاقه جنسيه بينه
وبين لورا وبيقول انه هي كمان كانت تحت
تاثير الكحول وانها كانت تبغى منه فلوس
ويبدو غلطت وانه ضربها بس علشان يدافع عن
نفسه
لمجرد قيل انه في المحكمه بدا شاحب وما
كان في تعابير على وجهه ساعه الحكم اما
لورا فبكيه وحضنت والدتها وقالت انه حطوا
القيود في يده واخذوا ومن وقت الحكم وحتى
قبلها كمان من وقت مثول سعد امام المحكمه
والموضوع ترند ومتصدر عربيه وبعيدا يعني
عن الصراع بين سعد ولوره داخل المحكمه
فقضيه سعد عامله صراع من نوع ثاني تماما
برا ففي وقت ناس كثيره احتفلت بالحكم
وسعدت بانه في شخص مغتصب اخذ جزازاته
بالقانون في ناس كثير شايف فتوه مظلوم
وبتدافع عنه وكثير من هؤلاء من المشاهير
فنانين ممثلين مطربين اعلاميين وغيره
وهبوا لدعم سعد والتضامن معه اكثر بيقولوا
مظلوم وبعضهم حتى بيقول بكل صراحه انه لو
يعني لو ابني وغلط ايش اعمل معه ما راح
ادمر مستقبله وانه لازم نوقف جنبه
طيب الكثير من المتضامنين معه سعد جالسين
بيهاجمونا نحنا شخصين في تفاعلكم
وشايفيننا متحملين ضد صعد لمجرد او عندنا
شيء ضده شخصيا او جزء من مؤامره عليه من
العلم يعني ما حد بينكر موهبه سعد ولا فنه
لكن هنا لازم ناخذ موقف ونوضح ولا يوم في
تفاعلكم كنا نحنا طرف في هذه القضيه او
غطينا اي شيء يتعلق من باب الراي او وجهه
نظرنا كله كان دوما كلام عما هو امام
القضاء او النظر في وصدر الحكم في كمان
احنا بنتكلم تحديدا على شخص ودين بالقضاء
ورغم ذلك كل مره تكلمنا في الموضوع عدنا
وزدنا انه سعد المجرد متى ما يحب له حق
الرد ولليوم بناكد على هذا الكلام من جديد
لكن اسمحوا لنا لمن يتعلق الامر بالاغتصاب
والاعتداء الجنسي ومو مره بالاكثر من مره
هذه لازم نذكرها نذكر فيها ونقولها مو مره
اكثر من مره ولمن يكون الشخص مدان بال لا
بل وصدر ضده حكم قضائي ايضا هنا الموضوع
ما فيه حياد هنا الوصفه الوحيد والدقيق هو
انه هذا الشخص مغتصب ودين بالقانون وحكم
بالقانون ايضا وفي كمان ضحايا ما نقدر
نتجاهل ماساتهم وكانه اللي مروا فيه مو
مهم هل العموم يوم ما يستانف المجرد او
يتحاكم في قضيه اخرى ويطلع براءه حنكون
ايضا اول من نتناول الموضوع بس اقتضى
التنويه في هذا الموضوع وحنكمل كلامنا مع
الصحفيه المتابعه للقضيه حنان عبد الله
اللي بتنضم الينا من باريس اهلا فيك معانا
حنان انا عارفه انه انت تعرضتي لكثير ايضا
من الهجوم خصوصا بعد المره الماضيه لما
انبهرتي معانا وتحدثنا عن القضيه اول شيء
خليني ابتدي معاكي هل عندك اي تفاصيل عن
موضوع الاستئناف او القضيه نفسها
اهلا ساره كما قلت يعني هناك حق الرد
بالنسبه لسعد ونعود لموضوع الاستئناف اكيد
هناك اجراءات في طور يعني العمل عليها من
طرف المحامين لطلب استئناف هذا الحكم خلال
عنده يعني تقريبا عشره ايام قبل يعني
بعدها سيكون حسب هذه قرارات المحكمه هذا
من جهه هناك قضيه تنتظره في محكمه
الجنايات بالجنوب الفرنسي بمنطقه حيث
شابه فرنسيه ايضا تقول بانه اعتدى عليها
جنسيا تفاصيل هذه القضيه ايضا وهذه
المحاكمه غير معروفه ولكننا سننتظر
الكلمه القضاء في هذا الاطار يعني حتى لو
خلاص انه مثلا تم الاستئناف وتاكد الحكم
هذا او ما تم الاستئناف وخلاص ثبت هذا
الحكم لسه امامه قضيه اخرى قد تزيد عليه
سنوات اضافيه يعني نحن بنقول
اكيد اكيد ساره هذه يعني الحكم الذي بد في
هذه القضيه التي ننتظرها منذ سبع سنوات
تقريبا لن يساهم في تسهيل الامور بالنسبه
للمحاكمه المقبله لانه فيها ايضا اعتداء
جنسي بمعنى انه هذه الكلمه تتكرر منذ
سنوات للاسف الشديد في مشوار سعد المجرد
الفني بمعنى اعتداء وتعنيف اعتداء وتعنيف
ان كان في امريكا ان كان في بلجيكا ان كان
في المغرب ان كان في فرنسا هذا ليس تحامل
القضاء قال كلمته في هذا الاطار ونحن لم
نقم الا بنقل ما قاله القضاء للعالم
العربي حتى تكون هناك صوره واضحه لانه
هناك تضليل للاسف اعلامي على السوشيال
ميديا حول المعلومات يعني هناك ما تقوله
المحكمه وما يتناقله الصحفي المحترف وهناك
ما تتناقله السوشيال ميديا وهذا ما جعل
هنا هذه الحرب يعني تنشا على منصار
الموضوع تقول انه ما في حكم من المحكمه ما
في ادانا ما الان لما جات الاداره صاروا
يقولوا لا مؤامره عليه لانه عربي او لانه
نجم او ما الى ذلك كيف بتردي على هذا
الكلام من ناحيه انه انت متابعه لقضايا
يعني
ساره انا كامراه بكل بساطه لا يمكن ان
ادعم قضيه كهذه انا لا اتحدث عن سعد
الانسان الذي اعرفه استضفت في برنامج
مرتين التقيت به اعرف الوالده والوالد
متابعيهم يعني متابعاهم واعرفهم منذ الصغر
انا اشتغلت في المغرب كصحفيه وكنت متابعه
لمشوار سعد المجرد الفني هذا لا يعفيني من
انني كامراه يمكن ان اشفق عليه لانه وضع
نفسه في هذه الورطه وبانه كان يعلم بانه
تحت تاثير المخدرات هو بيصير عنيف ويصبح
شخصا اخر ولا يتمالك نفسه ولا يتحكم في
تصرفاته لما تكون انت انسان او لما تكون
انت فنان معروف وتمثل بلد كما قلت في
السابق كالمغرب فعليك ان تتفادى مثل هذه
الامور وانا كامراه بحكم ان هناك امراه في
هذه القضيه ربما اليوم نتحدث عن سعد
المجرد كرجل ونقول عن لغه بانه هي التي
ذهبت وهي التي قامت وهي وهي وهي ونحن
نسينا بان هذه الفتاه كان في عمرها سنه
والقضاء الفرنسي يتعامل بنوع من يعني
خصوصيه كبيره جدا بالنسبه له فتاه في
العشرين لا تعرف شيء عندما تعنف تعنف
عندما تغتصب تغتصب والقضاء صارم نعود
ونقولها عندما تكون امراه في هذا الاطار
ونحن نساء في العالم العربي هناك قضايا
اغتصاب وتعنيف هناك نساء يعانين من هذا
الاطار من هذا الامر هناك اطفال يشاهدون
السوشيال ميديا ويشاهدون الاعلام لا يمكن
ان اكون اليوم انا كامراه يعني مسانده
لقضيه وليس لسعد هذا النوع من القضايا ولا
يمكن ان اقول لسعد سعد انت ابن بلدي وانت
مغربي مثلي وانا معك لا لا يمكن هناك
امراه يعني محور الكلام امراه تعرضت للعنف
لا يمكن
الان انت بتلمحي كثير لكثير من التغريدات
اللي كتبوها مشاهير وتحدثوا فيها عن دعمهم
لسعد وقالوا سعد انه يعني عربي سعد نجم
كبير سعد سعد صديقنا لابد ان نقف بجانبه
وفي تجاهل تام للضحيه في هذه القضيه
تحديدا او غيرها يعني
عندما تكون امراه وفتاه وبكل بساطه نساء
في قلب هذا النوع من القضايا فلا يمكن
لامراه الا ان تتضامن او بالاحرى ان تتفهم
وضع المراه في هذا الاطار يمكن ان نشفق
على سعد ولكن لا يمكن ان نتضامن معه
كاعلاميين مثلا انا اقول لاننا نمثل
واجهات اعلاميه هذه الواجهات هي تقوم بنوع
من التوعيه في دولنا العربيه وهذا شيء مهم
جدا اذا اردنا ان نتطرق لموضوع سعد فيجب
ان يكون الشخص حكيم وعقلاني ومنطقي في
تعامله مع هذه القضيه الانسان اخطا وكل
شخص منا يمكن ان يخطئ ولا يمكن ان نتضامن
مع ملفات من هذا النوع فقط لانه فيها رجل
وامراه والقانون قال كلمته في هذا الاطار
ولم يتبلى شخص على سعد يعني بهذا المعنى
البسيط طيب على العموم احنا حنتابع طبعا
الموضوع ونشوف تفاصيل
الاستئناف اذا في استئناف وتفاصيل القضيه
الاخرى تصدق يعني حنان صار لنا سبع سنين
ونحن بنتابع هذا الملف عده السنين الجريحه
على العموم بشكرك جدا على وجودك معانا
وعلى هذه المعلومات كانت معنا من باريس
الصحفيه المتابعه للقضيه حنان عبد الله
شكرا لك